veteran Blues defenseman tries to work it
up the board comes out in front here's a
shot on the way and Bennington called him on to
make a stop right off the bat on Steven Stan Co
H just inside the line Glen try to hold
it in there and it's moved out to center
right here's Hayden flurry flurry stays in the
lineup healthy scratch along the blue line is
Oh deflected in Janelle Banks it off of aimon
and a quick start for the lightning it's one
nothing lightning have come out with great
Authority and they they get a gift here this
time uh not so much and good Uno for getting
in there and taking advantage of see even the
cameraman thought the puck was going to go around
the wall and then he just gets it into the paint
area I aimont being covered but he just goes to
the net go to the open side and see what happens
he knows that youan know is going to put the puck
in there somehow goes in off him good start for
the lightning that may be possible did it go in
off his hand are they going to call for hand pass
they are still on the headsets down below us this
would be a great good there guys good looks there
yeah this will be a great start for the lighting
here on home ICE it's deceiving each camera angle
shows you something a little bit different
than dep reception and look at how look at
how long they finally have a verdict here
is West mccaulay after reviewing the play
the call on the ice is confirmed we have a
goal you know okay that's great so it's one
nothing but we still don't have any confirmation
from the officials that puck out in front of the
net with a top line and it's dead here comes
CRA the lead's leading score still down the
right side CRA to the middle for p big save
by Bennington on Nick Paul great Rush good
shot look at coov left side he's waiting for
the defenseman come on come on on the backand
COV has no problem making backhand passes he's
the best in the game right now with passing on
the back end that opens up so many things got
to work it against B up to the blow line abav
now to the middle chip the side here's a chance
coming in save by that's the that Rush up the
ice that was kyou who's at a hot stick bloody
back along the sidewall turnac steps up on him
that'll work it in front throws it out in front
into the scary his back high
loose squ F and it goes in by
score somebody found it and I think this is
going to be Tyler M making it two nothing Tampa
Bay this is typical of the way the lightning
have played in this first period the word is
intense you can have all the structure and
all the details you want you can draw it up
on paper all you want this has been an intense
first period every shift for the lightning and
that is the epitome of it bennington's fed
up here because he kind of gets pushed out
of the way by all the bodies but keep getting
the puck back into the blue paint you know the
St Louis coaches are going to want to look
and see can we help our goal tender because
the defense are doing it well enough the
lightning just will this one into the back
of the net just keep pushing and pushing and
I think they were looking to see if chance
or two Shen off the Stick of Point gathered by
flurry for he settles things down gets it away
to Nick Paul here's Point top the middle
dishes to COV COV hangs on takes the shot
stores M COV finds the seam and
makes it three nothing lightning
SC can take a page out of Nikita Cero's book
shooting from long distance puts the brakes
on that look at the double screen Nick Paul
an excellent job he's like a door opening and
closing COV gets up top but what does he see
he has to get it by the first guy but Nick
Paul is the door that's closed and then he'll
open the door watch him move out of the way
that may even have nicked them a little bit I'm
not sure they've adjusted the shot total by the
way after the first 20 minutes 14-4 is now the
official shot total in the opening period Here
Comes Nick perix in over the line for Tampa Bay
lets the puck all the way in Cuts back hangs on
in the just the COV Co shot the coov with his
second of the game great play from perix and
it's for nothing lightning who a Time times has
had problems with his confidence but does a real
nice patient job here puts the brakes on and then
makes the logical play kucherov does the right
thing and he covers up for FX you have to have a
forward cover up on defense when your defenseman
is deep in the offensive zone this is a bad goal
on Bennington that goes five hole but when you're
a goal scorer Nikita COV found the hole and it's
fours up sun to score shorthanded here he comes
drops it off shot save back look full that's is
down and he keeps it out Victor hitman's back but
now you got a two-on one so you got sunquist
on an angle he makes it who was ready for
that Celli finds the buck dishes to
Hegel to St Co pass was in his skates
they reload back to flurry his shot scores
hayen flurry with his first goal of the
season five nothing Tampa Bay the lightning D
coming through with a goal change too but the
lightning do a terrific job of moving the puck
around Steven stos might have had a goal but he
it went in his feet look at the traffic in front
so many bodies and Bennington having one of those
nights where he just can't find it excellent
work by Hayden flurry the end over Ender go
sails underneath the glove look at that one hit
a Rolling Puck stay down on it control it if you
tilt your shoulders K holds the line keeps it in
across to Bren sha Jen in across P Davis Big Save
By bitki The Rebound to the line and out Thomas
Thomas picks up that part and now it's Hegel
breaking away Brandon Hegel shorthanded in STO by
hoper gets his own rebound under the cornerback
and pull and then is blocked by Paro SOS up top
Victor hman loads slaps it down to stles and the
scores Nick Paul power play goal and it is 6
nothing but this is terrific they had a couple of
looks I really like Nick Paul walking out from the
beside the net to one time and this is how had
finished with Paul getting his stick presenting
it to Steven stos stammer knows what he wants
to do with it he'd already taken a look you see
Colton pero was guarding with his stick in the
middle he was assuming that his partner he'll
go Qui second unit out there for St Louis over
a minute gone in their power play here's Hayes
Haze to F back up to Kevin Hayes quick shot
ends up being a pass down low here's F again
rer scor for Justin folk power play goal and St
Louis gets one on the board Justin faul longtime
power play defenseman there's Brad Richard and
he come through with one Faulk will just inches
way down right into the middle of the ice it's
an excellent shot nice play good Puck control
gets down about the top of the circle vasileski
I believe is on the move out here as the shot
is coming it it beats him low I don't think it was
touched in front Robert Tallis as it goes into the
corner and this one is fining back down
picked up on the Fly save by vaski on
kyou another long run shot stopped by
vasileski again but that is it they
don't need it it is a thorough beating of
the St Louis Blues tonight 61 is the final